from creepy new hidden details in
Gilbert's magic shop to Mary's shifting
lip droop and secret Max dunny and
Ursula references yupikai movie lovers
I'm Jan and I've rewatched and paused
Hocus Pocus 2 all over again to hunt
down another stack of Easter eggs and
details you might have missed in the
movie Mary's Crooked jaw is part of her
iconic look however our awesome
eagle-eyed movie lovers have spotted
that in the sequel her lip droopers
shifted to the opposite side of her face
compared to the original movie initially
Mary's Crooked lip is on the same side
of her mouth as in the first film
keeping continuity between the two
movies however when Winnie slaps her in
the face the droop slips to the other
side where it remains for the rest of
the film Kathy and Jimmy revealed that
she had to make this change as after 30
years it's too difficult for her to
maintain the lip droop on the original
side I do love the clever little way
though that the filmmakers integrated
this change naturally into the sequel
now when the camera cuts to a giant post
of a mer trask's re-election campaign
you'll have to pause the movie and look
really closely at the buildings and the
background just over his shoulder and
behind Cassie is a house that will be
familiar to hardcore Hocus Pocus fans
yes it's Max and Danny's Family home
from the original movie and talking of
Danny the witch mother's red outfit in
the sequel is a homage to the red witch
costume that Dany wore for Halloween
back in the 90s in the sequel It's the
witch mother who gifts book to Winnie
potentially contradicting what was
established about the spell book in the
original film this is the spell book of
Winifred Sanderson it was given to her
by the Devil Himself and tons of our
movie lovers have been asking about this
so let me clarify why this probably
isn't an error or a plot hole it's very
likely that Alison's explanation is
simply based on unverified stories and
myths that the people of Salem had heard
about the Sanderson sisters over the
years and a assumed that they must be in
League with the devil perhaps because
thou eateth children in fact given that
in the sequel Billy butcherson goes out
of his way to say that the stories about
his and Winnie's relationship are untrue
we could also argue that other legends
about the sandersons might be incorrect
too there is however a tribute to that
original devil story on the replica
black flame candles that Gilbert sells
in his shop you can see this devil-like
figure here giving a book to some
characters wearing pointy witchy hats
the candles are also white and decorated
in red similar to the black flame candle
that Max lit in the first movie
and I found even more little tributes to
the first film in Gilbert's shop pause
as the Sanderson sisters make their
dramatic return to their old Cottage and
by the door you'll see two small wooden
cages which appear to be smaller
reproductions of the ones where the
witches imprisoned the bullies Jay and
Ice let us out of here yeah we're really
sorry by the way if you're wondering
what happened to the pair after they
were left hanging in the Witch's House
well there's a horrifying theory that
when young Gilbert found them there in
1993 he turned them into two new black
flame candles and I've got a video on
that which I'll link to at the end of
this video another hidden Easter egg in
the store is this book and its cover
design which is actually the poster for
bet middle a special event in search of
the Sanderson sisters there's also a
sneaky Cameo during Gilbert's
presentation about the legendary three
witches this woman dressed as a pirate
is Jan D'Angelo who wrote the screenplay
for Hocus Pocus 2. she's playing the
part of Liam's mum the kid who kept
asking questions about the sisters and
then asked this rather awkward one
what's a virgin ah that is a uh person
who has never lit a candle that's also a
reference to the original movie somewhat
weird obsession with Max's virginity are
you a virgin look I'll get a tattoo on
my forehead okay when Gilbert opens up
book after hearing the news that the
Sanders and sisters have returned it
sends a powerful ray of light through
the magic Shop's roof similar to the
burst of light it gave off in the
original movie after Max and Allison
opened it and which led the witches to
the spell books location in my first
paused video for Hocus Pocus 2 I
mentioned how Winnie's belt buckle was
identical to the witch mother's Broach
around her neck and as many of our
marvelous movie lovers have also pointed
out the three new girls all were the
same type of necklace in a tribute to
each of the Sanders and sisters outfits
so each necklace has three colored
stones a green one reddish purple one
and a brownish red one green is for
Winnie red for Sarah and brown is for
Mary each necklace also has several
five-pointed Stars similar to the star
in Winnie and the witch mother's
broaches and the moon symbols in each
necklace can be spotted scattered around
various embroidered designs on Winnie's
costume on top of that the young girl's
clothes are also a nod to the older
witches and their outfits Becca has a
green jacket that matches with Winnie
Izzy has a beige brown cardigan that
corresponds to Mary and Cassie's pink
jacket relates to Sarah actress Lilia
Buckingham has also said that Cassie's
cardigan is a deliberate callback to
Alison's cardigan hinting at a potential
connection between the two characters
plus her tie-dye shirt is a shout out to
Max's tie-dye top in the original movie
Melissa Escobedo has also said that her
burgundy cardigan is a tribute to
Alison's red hooded outfit in the first
movie I also noticed another subtle
connection between the new witches and
the Sanderson sisters when Becca and
Izzy cycle through Salem's historic
district to go into the woods they cycle
down the same street and go past the
same original buildings that the young
witch sisters originally ran through
when they fled Salem to go into the
Forbidden Forest in 1653 I mentioned in
my previous video a bunch of Easter eggs
and details hidden at the Salem scare
fest but I spotted a new one on my
re-watch when Becca and Izzy meet major
Trask for the first time just behind
them is a woman dressed as a witch she
is tied to a stake and getting
photographed by someone in a Puritan
costume this is a little nod to a myth
that witches were burned during the
Salem Witch Trials rather than hanged as
was actually the case and as we saw
happen to Winnie Mary and Sarah in the
first movie when the Sanderson sisters
stumble across the fantastically named
Apple plastic stall they're delighted to
discover what they believe is a man
being drowned and appropriately enough
below the stall's name is the phrase
rotten to the core a Disney Easter egg
in reference to the 2015 descendants
film which was directed by Kenny Ortega
who also directed the original Hocus
Pocus movie another interesting little
detail here is that descendants
introduced a new generation of
characters who were the children of
famous Disney new villains and in Hocus
Pocus 2 were introduced to a new Trio of
young witches who by the end take on the
legacy of the infamous Sanderson sisters
when the wicked sisters sing and enchant
the audience at the festival in Hocus
Pocus 2 among the crowd are three ladies
dressed as The Supremes A little hat tip
to the three Supremes who were also
Bewitched in the original movie as
another of our awesome movie lovers
Disney gal told us there's also someone
dressed as Ursula from Disney's A Little
Mermaid here with the villain's iconic
spiky white hair crown and Nautilus
necklace and among the dancing crowd is
a guy who has a look about him that
reminds me of the Reverend Trask from
Salem's early days another of our
marvelous movie lovers Cora says this
guy here is wearing a Halloween costume
of zombie Billy butcherson by the way
several more of our movie lovers have
said that Billy's stitches look like the
word kill but I think it might actually
be kiss a reference to the single kiss
that Billy says he only ever had with
Winnie I said one kiss with Winifred she
has signed my name for eternity there's
a funny callback to the first movie when
Winnie and Mary encounter a talking
virtual assistant inside the Trask home
sorry I didn't catch that really there
is a small woman trapped in that box
this is a hat tip to how the sisters
were tricked by technology in the first
movie where Max Allison and Danny
trapped them by using a cassette machine
playing back a French language lesson
after Becca traps the sanderson's inside
a salt Circle when he tests the force
field by pushing Sarah into the
invisible barrier similar to how she
pushed her onto the road outside their
Cottage to check if it was safe or not
it is a Black River
and when Trask arrives back to find the
witches locked in his garage as his
car's headlights illuminate the space
Winnie and her sister is panic thinking
the sunrise has come for them
oh no I don't want to die this moment is
a fun nod to have Max and Alison tricked
the sandersons in a similar way in the
first film when they were rescuing Danny
and Binks
and there's even more intriguing details
and Connections in the sequels such as
how winifred's eyes glow purple as she
casts the Magic Eye Maximus Bell similar
to The Witch mother's eyes when she uses
her powers I talk a lot more about that
plus where the cobweb is actually a
human who young Winnie turned into a cat
in my Hocus Pocus 2 Series video tap
here to watch that or follow the link in
the video description let me know what
your favorite moment was in Hocus Pocus
2 and if you spotted any other details
and if you enjoyed this video do leave a
thumbs up I really appreciate it thanks
for enjoying this movie with me and hope
you have a marvelous movie loving week
yippikai movie lovers